مستحضرا رمزيه المكان وتاريخه من مقره
الرئيسي بالعاصمه التونسيه اراد الاتحاد
العام التونسي للشغل لهذا التحرك ان يكون
الاكبر والاكثر حشدا جماهيريا امتدت
تحركات الاتحاد الى جميع الولايات
التونسيه بعد تصاعد عوامل تاجيج الخلاف
بينه وبين السلطه فبعد الملاحقات القضائيه
لعدد من اعضائها ترى المنظمه النقابيه ان
استهدافها بلغ حد طرد ضيوفها من النقابيين
الدوليين ومنع التضامن معها
وعمال العالم متحدين
الظلم وضد الظلم الحقوق الاقتصاديه
والاجتماعيه وضد ضرب الحق النقابي وحق
الاضراب كلفن ذلك ما كلفنا
اطراف سياسيه ومدنيه من مشارب مختلفه
ساندت تحرك الاتحاد الذي عبر بدوره عن
تضامنه مع جميع السياسيين والناشطين
المعتقلين مشددا على تمسكه بدوره الوطني
بعيدا عن الاستفافات السياسيه
تؤكد رسائل هذا التحرك العمالي الاتحاد
الشغل ان الملفات الاجتماعيه لم تعد
الشاغله الوحيد للمنظمه النقابيه فصاع
اليوم من اجل الوجود في ظل ما يصفه
الاتحاد باستهداف العمل النقابي وسعي
السلطه الى ضرب المؤسسه العماليه
الرئيس قيس سعيد استبق تحركات اتحاد الشغل
برسائل واضحه ومباشره رفض من خلالها
مشاركه اطراف اجنبيه في الاحتجاجات
النقابيه واعتبر من جهه اخرى ان تحركات
نقابات التعليم تندرج ضمن خانه الحسابات
السياسيه هناك من يريد ان يبدو بعض
الاشخاص الاجانب
للتظاهر في تونس
وهذا امر غير مقبولا على اي مقياس من
المقاييس
خلافات السلطه مع اتحاد الشغل ومشهد
الشارع المتململ ليست سوى احد اوجه المشهد
المتوتر في تونس فعلى وقع الملاحقات
القضائيه ايضا تحتد الازمه بين السلطه
والمعارضه السياسيه بعد اعتقال سياسيين
وناشطين بارزين من معارض سعيد ليضرب
الشارع ايضا موعدا مع تحرك احتجاجي اخر
تصر جبهه الانقاذ على تنفيذه رغم رفض
السلطات ميساء الفطناسي الجزيره تونس